this is cereth registered nurse re and
calm and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to assess the six
cardinal fields of gays now why do we
assess the six Cardinal fields of gays
well it tells us how well those extra
ocular muscles of the eyes are working
and there's six of them along with
allowing us to assess cranial nerves
three four and six so what I muscles are
we assessing we're assessing the
superior rectus muscle which helps us
with upward movement of the eye the
superior oblique which helps with
downward and outward movement of the eye
lateral rectus which helps with outward
movement medial rectus which helps with
inward movement inferior oblique which
helps with upward and outward movement
and lastly the inferior rectus which
helps with downward movement and when
we're performing this skill we're going
to have the patient move their eyes in
the following directions and the right
upper part the left lower the left upper
the right lower and then left to right
and while the patient is doing this we
are looking for a smooth motion of the
eye which would be a normal finding we
would not want the eyes to jerk or to
shake as they move and if they did that
would be known as nystagmus and how
we're gonna do that was we're gonna take
our pin line we're gonna hold it about
twelve to fourteen inches away from the
patient's nose and then what I want you
to do is keep your head still don't move
your head and just use your eyes to
watch where I move the pin line and as
you're doing this you're going to do
you're going to perform it in the six
cardinal fields of gaze and you're just
going to move it and you're looking for
any involuntary shaking of the eyes so
here we go
okay so that is how you assess the six
cardinal fields of gays thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos